[Jake]: One of the things we do around here at Corridor Crew is give you guys an appreciation
for the art and the craft of filmmaking and part of that appreciation comes from an understanding
So today we're doing the Jackie Chan Olympics. We've done other celebrity Olympics around here in the past
In fact, Nico holds the title for Office Tom Cruise
Sam holds the title of Office Indiana Jones
And today, we compete for the title of Office Jackie Chan!
fancy logo
Now, with Sam and Nico already holding Office titles,
we brought in two extra players to help round out the competition
We've got D from Node and we've got Wes, who's an awesome filmmaker and creator
You may have seen his stuff on Instagram or on Facebook
or you may have caught him right here on the Corridor Cast
[Jake]: I've got a bunch of Jackies around me
(off-camera) Which Jackie are you?
[Clint]: So today I'm coming in with Jackie Chan from "Wheels on Meals"
[D]: I'm Agent Lee from "Rush Hour"
The BEST Jackie Chan movie, in my opinion
[Jake]: I'm "Rumble in the Bronx" Jackie all the way
[Wes]: (perfect 'Drunken Master' impression) "Drunken Master" Jackie Chan
[Wren]: See, no one's representing older Jackie.
So that's what I am. I'm "The Foreigner".
I'm wizened, old Jackie Chan
[Clint]: I'm so glad that we decided to do this because I'm gonna win this whole thing, guys
*wow*
[Jake]: You hear that confidence? I think there's a lot more competition here today than he realized
myself included
[Wes]: I'm gonna win it for sure. I was raised in Japan
(off-camera) Really? Yea, I grew up in Okinawa.
[Wren and Wes speaking Japanese]
[Jake]: Now, in order to make this Jackie Chan official, we've set up several challenges inspired directly from his movies
Let's Get Started!
The first challenge is a simple Kip-up from the ground onto your feet (off-camera) "simple"
[Wes]: That's right. "Simple"
Jackie Chan does this- he gets knocked over and he does this perfect, beautiful Kip-up back onto his feet and he keeps fighting
[Nick]: Why is it called Kip-up, not Kick-up?
[Wren] (off-camera) ketchup
[Clint]: I dunno
(people saying "ketchup")
[D]: You're kicking and you're flipping, so it's a Kick-flip
[Nick and D]: It's a Kip
[Wren]: A Kick-flip
[D]: You put it together, equals Kip
A Flick-up, which just sounds not as-
[Nick]: No, that's not as cool
[Jake]: Each person is only going to get three tries to do this
So the worst person will be eliminated
[D]: Perfect. Perfect.
[Jake]: Then I think since you were the most hyped about this you got to go first, man.
[Clint]: All right, let's go!
Let's Go!
LET'S GO
[Jake]: (off-camera) And Clint,
THREE
TWO
ONE
GO!
(sounds of shock and awe)
(Clint dusts off hands like it's no big deal)
[D]: That was pretty good! (off camera) Smooth!
[D]: I didn't think that you were gonna do that THAT well on the first try!
[Wren]: SO SILENT
[D]: That was so easy. It was almost dead silent. That is really good- that was pretty good
[Wes]: Pretty nice. I think I'm gonna add some sauce to that, though
(off-camera) Wes wants it!
let's see it!
[Wes]: You guys ready for this?
[Jake]: And...
Three...
Two...
One...
Go!
(wig flies off)
(various Woo! sounds)
[Wren]: Dude, he did it so cleanly, he lost his hair!
[D]: Now the three-point landing is pretty clutch, too
[Wren]: Can you do a Kip-up?
[D]: I used to be able to do Kip-ups. I haven't done one in a really long time
[Wren]: Me neither, man!
(sucks teeth in fear)
[Jake]: "Rumble in the Bronx" Jackie. It's all on the line. Let's get this!
(supportive sounds for Jake)
Got my Jackie shoes on
(various) All right, ready?
(supportive clapping)
(struggled noise)
(supportive groans)
[D]: almost!
[Clint]: There's potential (2x)
[Wes]: That's a kick-puh (?)
(off-camera) Do a Tri-flip!
Do a Tri-flip
(various sounds of struggle and support)
[Jake]: C'mon!
(c'mon Jackie)
(wig flies off)
(failure)
("NO" in unison)
[Jake]: No!
(sorry, Jake)
[Jake]: Dude...
That's- that's the closest I've probably ever gotten, though. I summoned all of my Jackie Strength
[D]: I feel like I could get it after three. I don't know. It's been a looong time
(rubs hands)
(breathes)
[Jake]: Alright, D, good luck!
(perfect Agent Lee impression) Tucker, wait!
(Sci-fi sound)
(probably Wren) aieeee
(probably Clint) ohfff
(applause and wooos)
(more applause)
[Wren]: !!!
[D]:I did it! That was- not very clean, but I did it
[Wren] (worried) Oh man! I'm in trouble!
[Jake]: All right, Wren, good luck. It's between me and you, man.
Whoever does it worse!
I'm hoping old man Jackie doesn't have what he used to have
(strike one)
[D]: Close!
Wren, Wren- all you gotta do is when you go back you gotta
POP your front forward. Roll onto that and then, when you do it, SNAP that forward
(strike two)
(supportive laughter)
[Clint]: Wr- Wre- Wren, see it in your head and then be like, "I can do it!" and then you do i-
[Wren]: THAT'S WHAT I'M DOING!!!
[D]: Here it goes
(strike three)
(strike four)
(five)
(six)
(Wren ejecting himself from the competition)
[Wes]: Where you going???
(ten)
[D]: Wren ejected himself from the competition
[Clint]: *BOINNNG*
[Wes]: Wren is out there. He's in Studio City now. I don't see him anymore
[D]: Some say he's still trying to Kip-up
[Jake]: I'll take it, man. I'll take it. Let's move on to the next challenge
[Clint]: Alright. So in most Jackie Chan movies,
you'll see Jackie running up a wall and grabbing a high ledge in order to escape the bad guys
or maybe as a diversion through a chase scene
So that's what we're doing here today. We're at this wall
We're gonna grab some yellow gaff, wall run up this thing, slap a piece at the top. Whoever gets the highest wins
We're also taking into account number of steps on the wall. And, of course, style points because it is a Jackie Chan competition
[Wes]: Ready?
Be One With The Wall
Here we go!
(HAH)
(various whoas)
[D]: That was high!
[Wren]: Dude, that was really good!!!
[D]: You almost hit the grain
[Clint]: That's pretty good, man
[Wren]: Okay, now, TECHNICALLY that's only half stuck up there
[Clint]: nah, it- it's-
(anxious laughter)
[Jake]: Looks like it's 125 and a half (feet?)
[Wes]: yessssssss
[Jake]: I'll give it a shot.
[Clint]: Little-known fact: Jake's name does start with a J, the same letter in Jackie's first name. So...
(slap)
[D]:Pretty good, pretty good
[Clint]: That was really close!
[Jake]: That's not bad. I'll take it!
I'll take it
That's 120 and a half.
[D]: I was not expecting Jake to do that well
alrightalrightalright
[Jackie J]: Jackie, Good luck
[Jackie D]: Thank You, Jackie
(bangs knee into wall)
(off-camera) Valient Effort!
[D]: Ooh, I banged my knee again...
daaang
(sympathetic applause)
[Jake]: Let's get an opinion on that, guys
[D]: I SMACKED my knee into the wall again
[Jackie C]: Is Jackie okay?
[Jackie D]: Yeah. Jackie's alright
[Jake]: 119 and a half. So far, Wes is in first with 125 and a half. I'm in second with 120 and a half
D's in third with 119 and a half. We'll see how Clint fares. It's all up to him now
[Clint]: I'm goin' to the top
heh
(Clint psyching himself up)
(slap)
[All]: OHHHHHHH
(successful applause)
WOW
[Wren]: DUDE
I think Clint was definitely the winner here. Sorry- Jackie (C) was the winner here
Jackie (W) was second place and Jackie (J) was third place and Jackie (D) was fourth place
Jackie (D) also lost. Sorry, Jackie. At least you have a good retirement with the force
(sighs in defeat)
[Jake]: But, we have you guys as judges and what better than to have the two oldest Jackies being the judges with all that wisdom
Let's move on
[D]: That is so good!
Dude, this was such a good show
[Clint]: I know. It was the best!
[Uncle]: JACKIEEE
You dishonor your Uncle!
[Clint]: We were just doing some research on different Jackie Chan challenges
and we realized that Jackie is always very, very close with his uncle, no matter if it's the animated show
or if it's "Rumble the Bronx"
[D]: He's constantly yelling out "Uncle!"
[Keung]: Uncle!
Uncle!!!
[Uncle]: ...
[Keung]: UNCLE
UNCLEEEEEEE
[Clint]: ...and I figured that is a great leg up for me, because,
I bet you, out of everyone here in the office, I'm closest with my uncle.
[D]: I haven't talked to my uncle in years. I don't even know if he's still alive
[Clint]: How close are you with your uncle?
[Wes]: I just talked to my uncle yesterday.
[Wren]: (proudly) I'm very close with my UncleS
[Clint]: Look, guys. I can guarantee. I am THE closest with my uncle
[Wes]: Call him right now
[Clint]: First ring. First ring
[Wes]: Put him on speakerphone
[Wren]: Really?!
[Wren]: Uncle Jack...?
(first ring...)
[Clint]: Uncle Jack...
[Clint]: He usually picks u-
[Uncle Jack]: HEY. CLINT.
[D]: Wow. One ring
[Clint]: Uncle Jack, what's up, man!
It's bee- been uhhh
I guess since yesterday...
[Uncle Jack]: WHAT'S GOING ON IN THE STUDIO THERE TODAY???
We're just here doing like a Jackie Chan challenge that reminded me-
I'll give you a call
[Uncle Jackie]: OHHH
RIGH RIGHT THAT'S GREAT YEAH YEAH
ANYWAYS
LONG AS WE'RE ON THE SUBJECT OF THE VIDEOS
UM
YOUR MOM WANTED ME TO TELL YOU
TO TELL THE AUDIENCE ABOUT TODAY'S SPONSOR:
DID YOU DO THAT YET?
[Clint]: How do you know about today's sponsor?
[Uncle Jack]: That it's a brand new, free-to-play RPG
taking the mobile gaming landscape by storm!
It's got almost 10 million players worldwide
AND
you got over 400 champions. You can gather orcs, undead, night elves and more
I mean, I've been playing a crap-ton of this game.
It's been fantastic!
I mean you can assemble teams and play as factions. You can enjoy a fully-voiced-over story campaign
I mean, it's just lovely. But don't take my word for it- They've got over 200,000 reviews- all positive, of course!
[D]: Clint, there is no way that's your uncle!
[Uncle Jack]: WHAT YOU THINK ABOUT THAT?
[Clint]: I just think that's very odd and very specific
[Uncle Jack]: I didn't talk to Jake or anything but he said, "Go to the description of this video,
Click the links and for people that are new, they'll get 50,000 silver and a free epic champion to start"
HEY, HAVE FUN WITH YOUR JACKIE CHAN THING, MAN
[Clint]: Uh- real quick, just one last question for you. Where are you right now?
[Uncle Jack?]: UHHH
UMMM
I'M UHHH
IN MY LOUNGE
...
[Clint]: alright
bye, uncle
[Probably not Uncle Jack]: Click the link in the description (dial tone)
[Clint]: You guys heard it- Raid: Shadow Legends
Download it. It's a good time
[Clint]: Yo, Jay. Can I see your phone real quick?
[Jake]: why
[Clint]: Did you change my uncle's number to YOUR number?
[Jake]: ...
[Clint]: lemme see your phone, please
(sounds of struggle)
(Download Raid: Shadow Legends)
[Jake]: Okay, the next challenge is the obstacle course
Now, in every Jackie Chan movie,
he's going under something, he's going over something, he's hopping into cars, through windows-
and this challenge is directly inspired by those moments
You're gonna start here at the cone. You're gonna go this way --->
OVER the first sawhorse
under the second- without spilling any water- and then to the car, through the window and into the seat...
*HONK*
...and honk the horn. Time stops when you honk the horn.
May the fastest man win
[Clint]: Alright, so Jackie from "Wheels on Meals" is up first
gotta be quick
The water part is the part I am most worried about
How am I gonna sneak under that
without knocking any water down?
(???)
I'm also kind of scared this guy- look at these ABS, man
(Extreme Abs)
See, I don't have those, man. I got like a pack. I got a pack, alright
[Jake]: Clint, you're gonna go start at the cone
I'm gonna yell, "Three, two, one, Go!", the timer will start on "Go!" and it will keep going until you honk the horn
[Clint]: Ready!
(shoes are ready)
[Jake]: Ready?
[Clint]: *is ready*
[Jake]: And three..
two
One
GO
*HONK*
[Wren]: wut
WHAT
[D]: Six point one nine
[Wren]: That was ridiculous!!!
(off-camera) That's how it's done!
That was so fast!
[Jake]: Wow. Alright, I'm gonna try it!
See, I'm playing it up because the guys don't know that I was a
Division One, two-time All-American in Track and Field
and I also did the steeplechase so jumping over things- Not a problem for me!
Oh, yeah!
[Wes]: alright, three...
two...
One
GO
*HONK*
[All]: ???!!!???
(way to go, Jake)
[D]: 6.04 (seconds)
[Jake]: WOOOOO.04
[Clint]: Point zero eight seconds faster???
wowwwwwww
What, you forgot? I'm a two-time Division I All-American -and I still can't do a Kip-up!
[Clint]: I am nervous. I'm  legit nervous.
[Wes]: uh- You know what? I'm visualizing it right now
[Jackie J]: Alright, good luck, Jackie!
[Jackie W]: Thank you, Jackie
Three
Two
One
GO
*HONK*
*HONKHONKHONK*
*honk*
(sound of Clint's defeat)
[Jake]: CLINT'S OUT
[Clint]: NOOOOOOO
[Wes]: !!!!!!!
*phewww*
[Clint]: I thought I could do it...
[Jake]: Wes, you had so much height over the first sawhorse!
Clint, you are honorable in victory as well as defeat
[Clint]: I wish you both the best in the final challenge. Thank you
*slide whistle*
Guys, welcome to the finals
We have two born and bred Jackies right in front of us here. This is a very, very special final competition here
This is timeout
You all remember the scene in "Drunken Master",
when Jackie acts up and gets put in timeout by his dad, that's what we're doing here today
We're gonna balance five cups of water-
one on the head, two on the shoulders, two on the knees. Fill it with very hot boiling water
First person to spill any of the water or fall down from muscle fatigue loses
and the other person is crowned
The Office Jackie Chan
Let's get to it.
[Wes}: I made it this far on my first day
I've been doing martial arts my whole life
Core stances? It's like walking
[Jake]: I'm meditating very hard
But I'm thinking confident thoughts
[D]: The whole idea of this is to be able to keep your cool under ANY obstacle that comes your way
[Wren]: *is obstacle*
!!!
[Wes]: Bruce Lee always said, "Be like water..."
[Bruce Lee]: be water, my friend...
and our bodies are 90% water.
duh!
[D]: Whoever wins this is gonna be the Office Jackie Chan. I'm sad It's not me-
the ONLY Asian person in the office (um what)
(guilty white laughter)
[Jake]: We're taking the wigs out for the ease of the water placement on the head
[Wren]: Alright, shoulders are set!
[Jake]: And, three... two... ooone...
Box-off!
[D]: Knees are on. You guys are good!
That's it. That's it
(off-camera) Alright, we're in
[D]: Wes has a really nice, solid low-stance
[Wren]: but their shoulders-
[D]: Jake also has the Jackie shoes on
Oh, I see some wobble right here. You've got some wibb-wobbs going on on this water right here
Jake is concentrating with his eyes closed. He's trying so hard.
Wes is solid as a rock
Jake's wobbling a little bit, but he's got the soul of a warrior
[D]: *is obstacle*
[Wren]: *OBSTACLE*
(tense, royalty-free music)
[D]: (low-pitch, slowed down) heee's gooot theee sooouuul offf theee warriorrrrrrr
*warrior breathing*
*solid as a rock*
Chiii of theee Warrriooorrrrrrr
*Chi falling to the floor*
[Jake]: NOOO
NOOOOOOO
*more Chi falling*
*NOOOOOOO in slow-mo*
[D]: The Office Jackie isn't even normally in this office
Wes is crowned, The Office Jackie!
Office Jackie!!!
[Office Jackie]: YESSS!!!
(cheers of victory)
I mean- Honestly guys, like, Corridor Digital is probably my favorite channel on YouTube
So, um- being part of the legacy?
*SMACK*
*phewww*
[D]: Since you are the winner of the
Jackie Chan Office Challenge
You are LEGALLY now allowed to wear any Jackie Chan costume- and no one can question it.
Congratulations, Jackie
[Office Jackie Chan]: It's been a true honor
I thank you, guys
[Non-Jackies]: Thank You, Jackie
[Wren The Unworthy]: I'm not worthy of this windbreaker!
[Jake The All-American]: It's a good day seeing a man win the Celebrity Olympics
*victorious noises*
Now we have an Office Tom Cruise,
an Office Indiana Jones,
an Office Jackie Chan
If you have an idea on another movie star Olympics you think we should do
let us know in the comments below.
We'd love to check it out
[Wes]: Office Wesley Snipes...
[Clint]: Office Mr. Bean? Office Mr. Bean?
Office John Goodman!